[Música]
hola desde los estudios de radio canadá
internacional de montreal va un saludo
muy cordial a todos nuestros oyentes
internautas y también lectores que nos
siguen en este momento en directo por
medio de facebook de youtube y también
desde nuestro sitio web eres en este
punto sea aprovechamos también para
agradecerles aquí su presencia que nos
acompañan todos los viernes muchísimas
gracias en estudio
pablo gómez barrios hola pablo leonardo
bien y tenemos un invitado viene
especial hoy matías o lydia que ese hola
matías que se vamos a presentar lo es el
director de contenido multimedia en el
festival del mundo árabe que es un
festival extraordinario que se lleva a
cabo aquí en montreal en sus inicios y
hasta hace poco tiempo era un festival
solamente el único de este tipo en
américa del norte vamos a conversar con
matías en unos
minutos antes de eso vamos a hablar un
poco de cómo fue la semana para ustedes
bien se terminaron las elecciones
tenemos un nuevo primer ministro como
dijo pablo el otro día minoritario
fuerte fuerte de radio canadá que dijo
va a depender como es el gobierno puede
ser minoritario fuerte o minar y está
minoritario débil débil pero fue fuerte
definitivamente fuerte porque le da
cierta la actitud al primer ministro
georges centro y ya lo demostró en sus
últimas declaraciones donde decía que el
proyecto de oleoducto de transmountain
se va y ya está ya arrancó ya está en
en camino y eso hay que decirlo y el
motivo de disputas muy fuertes en canadá
por un lado alberta y saskatchewan que
quieren a toda costa que ese oleoducto
nazca de ser transbordados para relevar
la economía exactamente es un oleoducto
que llevaría el petróleo de la provincia
de alberta y de saskatchewan por
columbia británica hacia fuera y lo
importante es que dice cuando decíamos
hablábamos de débil y de fuerte cuando
él dice fuerte y la declaración que hizo
es que dijo que no los partidos
minoritarios
en el parlamento no podían intervenir no
serían consultados finalmente porque
está seguro que él
pasa para hacerlo los conservadores
además van a estar con él en este caso
los observadores apoyan desde siempre a
nosotros claro a diferencia de la
oposición de que ve que las provincias
del este ya la oposición fuertísima de
columbia británica entonces de si hay
que decir justamente que crudo
no obtuvo un asiento ni en alberta ni en
saskatchewan y él sabe que eso se debe
en parte en gran parte a ésta este
retraso en la implementación de la de la
creación del oleoducto ahora lo que es
cierto es que podrá ir a buscar
senadores y podrán nombrar senadores de
las provincias en las que no está
representado su partido político podrá
nombrar incluso a personas que tengan
una incidencia digamos en términos de
consultantes de votación en el
parlamento los senadores no votan
pero de alguna manera lo que decían
algunos analistas esta semana es que iba
a lograr por lo menos durante dos años
mantener una cierta estabilidad cabo ni
se va a asociar con partidos políticos
dependiendo del proyecto de ley o los
intereses de cada uno finalmente debería
ser así porque gobierna ahora todos los
canadienses y aún convencen si no
ponerse de acuerdo para que ciertos
proyectos salgan con uno o con otro
pasemos a temas más serios es una
noticia que le dio hoy leonardo endo le
comento esto en la sección cuando
estábamos trabajando y que me parece
importantísimo que ustedes estén al
tanto de esta noticia vamos tenemos un
vídeo que vamos a ir mostrando tiene un
pie la vídeo
y leonardo que se trata de una casa de
teléfono celular
la cobertura que unos investigadores de
gran bretaña y francia- crearon esta
carcasa con piel artificial prendiera
artificial que parece que es verdadera
pero el invento que fascina pero que
pone la piel de gallina justamente
porque si ustedes están viendo es
realmente asqueroso no quiere exacto ahí
le está haciendo la vida y ya que
funcionemos con las masas
hasta el punto de que uno perezca y en
la computadora si está conectada con la
carcasa dice muy y se ríe entonces
es realmente puede ser genial pero es
asqueroso ahora si el invento nació de
la imaginación los científicos
británicos y franceses que desarrollaron
esta membrana artificial que se asemeja
a la piel humana no sólo en apariencia
sino también por supuesto en lo que
estamos viendo las capacidades
sensoriales en la membrana que cubre los
dispositivos como smartphones
lo que es bonito puedes sentir esos
gestos las interacciones con una
cosquilla las caricias que es como hacer
caricias al vacío a la nada
eso
esto me da un poquito de impresión no
tiene que ver con la posibilidad de
ejecutar digamos desde el modo práctico
de ejecutar acciones con el teléfono
desde atrás y pueden usarlo en este caso
por ejemplo como mouse
honestamente para qué sirve para nada
para no seguramente eso sirve para otras
investigas para quemados por ejemplo
para la gente que dice pero qué mentiras
es la más skin un prototipo y lo que
hace es esa carcasa le da la posibilidad
a esa cosa tan impresionante de
comunicarse con el teléfono mediante
tacto caricias una piel tersa si es
demasiado bueno ahora vamos a la parte
más seria todas medias esto es en serio
este es en serio estamos aquí con matías
un asistente a la creación artística y
director de contenidos multimedia en el
festival del mundo árabe
es un festival que se está llevando a
cabo que en realidad este año es el
vigésimo entonces ya tiene 20
gales en su haber vamos a ver un vídeo
un pequeño vídeo pierre él quiere que no
se ve entonces vamos a ver un pequeño
vídeo que muestra un poco lo que
significa este festival lo que vamos a
ver en este festival escuchemos además
[Música]
i
ah
[Música]
me parece cosas maravillosas que podemos
ver en este festival y siempre estoy
pensando en términos es un festival del
mundo árabe de montreal pensando además
que esto es de un gran interés para la
gente que nos está escuchando en américa
latina porque hay así que hay muchísimos
inmigrantes de origen árabe que vinieron
desde hace más de un siglo
pienso en brasil pienso en chile pienso
en argentina colombia venezuela entonces
se creo que esto puede interesarles como
digamos conocer un poco lo que está
sucediendo acá la última estadística que
yo manejo matías es que acá en 2014
había unos 750.000 canadienses de origen
árabe ahora eso fue hace 5 años en el
entretanto hubo esta inmigración que
llegó los 3 más de 30 mil sirios que
llegaron con un programa especial
después llegaron así que no sé
exactamente cuántos eran pero es una
población que está creciendo muchísimo
en canadá encontramos un poco ahora
sobre este festival que tiene por
objetivo
un acercamiento un diálogo entre la
cultura o las culturas árabes con las
occidentales pues sí la verdad es que el
festival ópera ese puente entre las
culturas occidentales y árabes en el
mundo árabe hay varios mundos también la
gente que por una palabra pues se define
el árabe pero en realidad es que es muy
grande ese mundo y tiene muchos siglos
también y pues el trabajo de ese
festival pues me parece que es múltiple
pues somos el único festival en américa
del norte que propone tantos
espectáculos combinando calidad
originalidad y que toma riesgos porque
también hacemos venir artistas del
internacional hay que tener las visas
hay que crear creaciones pues inventar
espectáculos cada vez vamos haciendo más
creaciones del festival es decir que los
inventamos con los artistas vamos
trabajando con ellos son 20 años es que
ya pueden decir ustedes que el festival
alcanzó su madurez
llegando a su madurez y si es me imagino
que sí cómo se manifiesta esto en el
festival pues digamos que la vida del
festival es como un poco un equilibrista
que es la temática de esta edición que
se llama así al mediodía del mundo 20
años
es un título muy poético muy muy lírico
pero también habla bien realista
sí porque hubieron varios
acontecimientos que han cambiado un poco
el mundo occidental y la mirada hacia el
mundo árabe el primero fue el atentado
del 11 de septiembre del 2001 y la
realidad es que pues el festival logró
sobrepasar ese ese ese momento de
incertidumbre en el que pues no se
sabían quién era esa gente y los que de
coss venían al 70% de los espectáculos
lo que cambió fue en el 2007
el año en el que hubieron los monjes un
habla en el que ahí pues yo no sé si
será por qué es uno de los
acomodamientos y nosotros decíamos aquí
en que ve que es razonable si es decir
propiciará que las que se permitimos o
no de lo demás la idea general que se
mantuvo en los medios y yo creo que pues
el fenómeno mediático pues impactó el
público que ve coque pues en el 2007
fueron peces la cifra bajó hasta 7 por
ciento de públicos y dieron para seguir
hay que ser valiente hay que ser muy
valiente y ahí también está lo de la
temática que miramos esos 20 años y pues
los miramos sin sin ilusiones con
realismo y sin sentimiento de fracaso
somos fuertes sabemos lo que lo que es
difícil vivimos entre digamos dos placas
grandes que son el mundo árabe
y el mundo occidental y cada uno va
proyectando en ese festival que somos
nosotros sus miedos o sin sus interés
incertidumbres y cada uno se va como
acusando de lo que sea y nosotros
estamos aquí en la mitad de nuestras
misiones pues muy cultural permitir ese
diálogo y permitir ese diálogo por la
cultura y ver que más allá de la
política de la ideología y la propaganda
digamos hay una cultura real y hay una
historia también y que hay conexiones
entre esas esas culturas pero si a mí me
llama la atención no habla usted de este
proyecto como si fuera suyo usted tiene
trabajando ahí cinco años mismo pero
como se escuchó un acento un poco
colombiano esperaba entonces como llegó
una persona como usted a este proyecto
del festival del mundo árabe pues sí la
motivación el entusiasmo y el
enamoramiento pues porque me gustó mucho
el festival yo empecé a trabajar ahí
como camarógrafo y pues poquito a poco
pues estuve como acercándome cada vez
más al festival y me pareció
espectacular pues la misión del festival
las propuestas artísticas culturales y
también puede ser
es un festival muy completo porque hay
cine hay y artes escénicas escénicas
gratis y también otras que hay que toca
pagar pero es accesible para cada uno y
también hay conferencias hay como unas
15 a 20 conferencias debates para temas
como sobre temas pueden ser temas
históricos como pueden ser socios
políticos geográficos este año tenemos
un tema sobre el tratado de versalles
que al final de la primera guerra
mundial va redefiniendo pues las
fronteras en el mundo árabe y pues es
para ver las raíces de lo que vivimos
hoy pues se puede encontrar en ese
tratado por ejemplo o sea que hay una
voluntad como como de de comunicar de
dialogar con la gente y nosotros no
tenemos como no queremos imponer una
ideología o un mensaje solo queremos
como estimular y hacer viva esa cultura
que tiene muchas dimensiones y que hace
parte de montreal porque hay una
población árabe
importante
y pues la historia ha mostrado que los
que vemos pues han tenido un interés
importantísimo hacia esa cultura
si matías equivocaste ahorita en la
parte internacional del festival cuales
hoy en día 20 años más tarde la parte de
internacional con respecto a la parte de
local porque me imagino que hay muchos
artistas locales de accede por supuesto
y aquí de cosas que se presentan en este
festival cuál es más o menos la parte
pues no tengo cifras pero le puedo
asegurar que nosotros trabajamos pero
tenemos colaboraciones de largo tiempo
con músicos de aquí también buscamos
nuevos músicos
necesitamos esos músicos locales pues
porque ellos hacen vivir esas culturas
múltiples aquí en canadá o sea que los
necesitamos y también pues armamos
conexiones con los artistas del
internacional porque permitimos que los
músicos de aquí puedan tocar con los
músicos o cantantes grandes que vienen
del internacional y el contenido tiene
que ser producido por gente que
necesariamente tiene orígenes árabes no
puede ser no sé por ejemplo aunque
piense que tenga amor por la amor por la
cultura y hacer el festival no es un
festival étnico o ideológico es un
festival que lleva pues es muy abierto
hay una apertura solo toca como de
joleon ahora como puedes tener una
pasión con algo que tiene que ver con el
mundo árabe el mundo árabe es algo muy
muy grande muy vasto sí o sea que pueden
haber
vinieron los cobos sufíes que son
gringos que son gringos que les encanta
pues se convirtieron al sufismo pues y
cantan en árabe tocan en música árabe y
vinieron creo que en el como los
vaqueros y el festival también este año
le da un lugar muy especial a la mujer
vamos a ver un vídeo lo puede enviar
tierra y escuchemos la voz de esa mujer
que a mi hijo cuando le escuché dije la
vamos a mostrar
[Música]
y
ella es y es una de las grandes voces
que están presentes en este festival
porque porque ustedes decidieron dar es
la tercera vez que le dan un lugar
especial a las mujeres en el festival
hay alguna razón particular pues la
verdad es que no es la tercera vez pero
ya no se encuentran las veces en la que
la mujer ha estado
en el tercer homenaje especial creo de
la mujer o de un cool el halo de
canciones porque si uno mira las
temáticas y los conciertos de la
historia el festival la mujer siempre
tuvo un lugar muy importante en el
festival del mundo árabe hubieron varias
en varios espectáculos como poniendo en
homenaje a la mujer sobre su poder sobre
lo que inspira sobre lo que como va
alimentando el mundo árabe porque tenía
muchos prejuicios al respecto y pues
para ésta este 20 años este año 20 era
la ocasión también de
de volver a las temáticas iniciales del
festival por ejemplo el lugar de la
mujer pero también los cantos sagrados
pues porque es otra parte del festival
somos un festival laico pero que no
rechazamos la religión en el sentido que
ha dado cultura a la música o sea que
por ejemplo la apertura esta noche y la
mujer canto dios es un espectáculo que
reúne a más de 25 mujeres y cada
monoteísmo el judío el cristiano y el
musulmán es representado por una
cantante y músicos
de acuerdo entonces hay que decir
justamente este festival empieza hoy es
casi un mes de duración entonces en
nuestro sitio web va a haber otros
vídeos donde justamente hablo de cantos
sagrados que me parece extraordinario
también te agradecemos muchísimo
de origen colombiano porque te
interesaste en esto porque esa pasión
porque sé por qué es ese empuje fue del
azar yo no conocía nada al mundo árabe
para ser honesto pero cuando me
contrataron para un espectáculo que me
tocaba filmar pues me quedé ahí
impresionado y quise como saber más y
participar en ese proyecto y ahí como lo
dije antes un poquito a poco pues
entendí pues la importancia de este
festival de montreal quebec canadá
américa del norte y conociendo por lo
que está pasando hoy en día en el mundo
y como cada mundo occidental y árabe se
va confrontando me parece que por el
lado cultural y por el lado social es un
festival importante que además se ya
está dando hijos aquí en canarias
podemos decir que en él también el
festival de toronto hace tres años que
está ya existiendo y sociales
contribuyeron también a ayudarles a la
creamos elevadora forma social de
montreal pasamos a toronto y quién sabe
después por otros lugares de canadá
claro y también para mencionarlo ayudan
pues inspiramos el festival árabes que
es en montpellier en francia
la respuesta con respecto a lo que decía
leonardo porque siendo colombiano hasta
ahí es porque los colombianos están por
todo un chiste en un momento dado que
decía que cuando neil amstrong puso el
pie en la luna al bajarse se compró como
un colombiano cada día y cada vez más
muchísimas gracias
mucha suerte con este festival vamos a
pasar ahora al bloque de la aplicación
de leonardo y vamos a hablar de la
aplicación seguimos pidiendo a la gente
que baje
unas cifras en las cifras muy grandes
importantes de la sección francesa
la aplicación nosotros estamos más para
atrás de menos
pero estamos intentando de que cientos y
cientos y cientos de más bajen nuestra
aplicación también así que les damos la
opción ahí esta semana va a subir
nuevamente la promoción de las
aplicaciones en la barra lateral del
sitio de internet hacia la parte de
arriba entonces directamente haciendo
clic ahí uno puede entrar a una página
que indica si no tienen teléfono con
android o un teléfono con apple si cómo
hacer para ir a bajar justamente la
aplicación y hay gente que nos escribe y
que nos dice que la aplicación funciona
súper bien así que los invitamos con
mucho cariño a que vayan ya société de
internet y bajen la aplicación de radio
canadá internacional excelente ahora
tenemos la participación de otro oyente
nuestro que nos envía un vídeo desde
uruguay hay que decir que este domingo
pues hay elecciones en uruguay no sólo
en argentina también en uruguay paloma
exactamente ya hicieron su cierre de
campaña en los candidatos a la
presidencia leonora recordemos que por
el partido el frente amplio que está en
el poder actualmente se presenta daniel
martín
y por el partido nacional que es de
centroderecha está el ex senador luis
lacalle pou entonces
no sé cómo lo pronunció dos maneras como
elegirán a un presidente este domingo
los uruguayos pero también están
eligiendo y están votando de alguna
manera por una en realidad el partido
nacional presentó un proyecto de ley
para una reforma para hacer más firme la
cuestión de la seguridad en el país
entonces de alguna manera votar por el
partido nacional o votar por el frente
amplio representa destrucción educación
es ahora esta reforma o no exacto y lo
que sí se dice que van a ser las
elecciones muy reñidas desde hace mucho
tiempo en ecuador es digo en uruguay y
que también existe la probabilidad según
dicen los analistas de una segunda
vuelta que sería el 25 de noviembre si
es que es necesario
bueno pues nuestro oyente gustavo lucas
desde uruguay justamente nos envió un
vídeo veamos escuchemos
[Música]
buenas tardes este es un informe para
radio canadá internacional el castor
mensajero acá estamos de su desfile
la caravana de cierre de campaña de un
partido político partido nacional
de uruguay
jueves
cierra la campaña electoral dado que en
el país se pronuncia a partir de la cedh
hora del viernes la de electoral hacia
las elecciones del día domingo 27
como decía se trata del partido nacional
uno de los contendientes que lleva
a la cabeza la candidatura de él
vine a lacalle pou
justamente contendiente hacia el partido
que actualmente está en el gobierno que
es el frente amplio que lleva la
candidatura de daniel martínez
por lo tanto aquí estamos viendo un
la caravana como decía la caravana en el
cierre de campaña de este el partido
nacional recordando que el 27 de octubre
el próximo domingo se celebrará la
primera vuelta de las elecciones en
uruguay mi nombre es gustavo lucas
muchísimas gracias entonces gustavo
muchísimas gracias y ven qué interesante
que es cuando nos envían estos vídeos
tenemos la sensación pues simplemente es
para ver cómo fue con el nuestro oyente
anterior desde chequia de la república
checa que nos mandó también un vídeo
entonces es interesante la participación
de los oyentes y internautas y lectores
digo yo porque cada vez parece que nos
leen mucho y los invitamos calurosamente
a que participe y que nos envíen fotos
que nos envíen vídeos como acaban de ver
en fin este programa es el suyo como
siempre lo ha sido y los invitamos a que
participen aquí tengo mensajes de miriam
alarcón dice hola como estan yo feliz
porque el domingo vamos a votar aquí en
argentina miriam es una de nuestras dos
fans y lo que pedimos para las
elecciones bueno del uruguay y de la
argentina puntualmente que se realicen
tranquilamente en paz y si algo salga
bien
y que gane el mejor el mejor para el
mejor para la situación que saque las
cosas adelante porque desde afuera se ve
que se está sufriendo mucho porque no
siempre gana el mejor
no siempre gana los mejores proyectos y
esperemos también que disminuya la
violencia en chile hay muchísima
violencia y denuncias de violaciones de
derechos humanos muy fuertes en chile
bueno ahora hay una comisión de derechos
humanos de las naciones unidas también
que fue a investigar lo que está
sucediendo allí vamos a entrar ahora
vamos a leer un poco los comentarios de
nuestros oyentes porque dejamos pasar
hace un tiempo siempre tenemos otras
cosas y se nos van acumulando entonces
podemos empezar con un mensaje
cualquiera y bueno desde plan de canadá
para atraer miradas de sanciones remotas
del país
eso se llama entre el 'enano' más buen
día mi nombre es elizabeth torres en
vivo en colombia con mi esposo y mis dos
hijos me pueden orientar de cómo
solicitar a la provincia de aceptación
para hacer el parte del plan piloto
queremos vivir en canadá y le decimos a
elisabeth torres garcía y a todos los
que escriban mensajes similares que
tienen que ir a los sitios de internet
del gobierno de canadá y fijarse digamos
justamente en la rúbrica que dice plan
piloto para poder ver cuáles son las
bases las bases nosotros no las tenemos
así que la mejor manera es consultar en
los organismos oficiales
exactamente tengo aquí un mensaje de
juan caro acá sobre el tema del español
y los adultos mayores en canadá es
informando interesante sí y él dice
nunca es tarde para agradecer la
publicación gracias canadá desde
edmonton alberta canadá
juancar oca que comentaba este reportaje
que es de rufo valencia y que es un
formato largo es un reportaje largo que
puede formar los 200 reportajes
especiales y aquí tengo un mensaje de
miguel ángel ortiz lópez que se con
respecto a manifestación en ciudad de
méxico contra manuel lópez
obrador este domingo y miguel ángel dice
una precisión señor pablo gómez barrios
presencié personalmente esta
manifestación y no fueron miles de
personas a qué se refiere los asistentes
opositores al presidente de méxico
fueron cientos y difícilmente llegaron a
dos millares por el nombre de su página
intuyo que la fuente de información para
usted son los medios de comunicación
preponderantes y estos no siempre
reflejan la realidad de mi país pues
está comprobado que escriben y opinan
por consigna lo que quiero pensar no es
su caso cordiales saludos miguel ángel
ortiz lópez que le puedo decir a miguel
ángel que nosotros pues trabajamos con
las informaciones que nos llegan de las
agencias de prensa y trabajamos también
con los periódicos y los medios locales
que entonces pese siempre tratamos de
mantener un equilibrio en ese sentido
justamente para no dejarnos llevar
las tendencias de las grandes agencias
de prensa y tenemos que verificar esas
informaciones en todo caso eso es una
obliga a gradecer la obligación de tener
por lo menos tres fuentes igualmente
siempre haber alguien que le guste o sea
eso es parte de nuestro trabajo también
no aceptar que hay gente que no está de
acuerdo y que no está contenta
y creo que también es el rol que juegan
nuestros oyentes justamente cuando
gustavo nos hace un informe desde
uruguay cuando otro con otro de nuestros
oyentes nos hace un informe por qué es
lo que ellos están viendo en el terreno
entonces muchas gracias a miles para los
dos sentidos exactamente yo tengo un
mensaje aquí que me causa mucho placer
es de miriam alarcón justamente hola
miriam si el tema es margaret atwood
gana el segundo premio booker por los
testamentos estos testamentos se acaba
de salir hace un mes
la dignidad de la sirvienta escarlata
del primer que se hizo muy conocida
sobre todo por la serie televisiva que
ya van por la tercera sesión creo y dice
he leído un solo libro la sirvienta voy
a poner algún otro título de margaret en
mi lista y dice estoy muy intrigada con
la obra de bernardino bernardino es la
otra persona mujer que ganó también el
premio booker que fue compartido por
atwood y bernardina espero entonces
encontrarlo en español muchísimas
gracias dice miriam muchísimas gracias a
vos miren tengo aquí más mensajes en
este caso gustavo lucra dice gracias a
ustedes por la oportunidad participar
como dijo leonardo voy a tener que
trabajar con ustedes en canadá dice así
que lo explicamos ha gustado para que
venga a trabajar con nosotros y miriam
alarcón dice que gane el que tenga un
proyecto de desarrollo con equidad con
eso creo que vamos a estar mejor creo
que es bastante interesante esa postura
si tengo aquí otro mensaje
que comenta el tema nueva ley y niños
indocumentados podrán estudiar
gratuitamente en quebec y mario cárdenas
pregunta de verdad pueden los niños sin
estatus legal estudiar en las primarias
de quebec y le contestamos que si hay un
proyecto de ley a quien que pasó
recientemente en el que no se les puede
pedir a los papás que quieran inscribir
a sus hijos tengan documentos o ningún
documento migratorio entonces con que
lleven una prueba de la dirección para
saber que el niño corresponde a esa
escuela que a ese niño le corresponde
esa escuela entonces con eso es
suficiente no saben en qué demuestra la
cuestión de derechos humanos se pueden
aplicar ningún niño puede quedar fuera
del sistema escolar al 30 exactamente
entonces se disfrutarán el temario y
dice hoy trate link a él dice que trató
de registrar a su hija y le pidieron el
certificado de selección de quebec y la
visa de estudio permiso de estudio bueno
pues en las escuelas no tienen derecho
de pedirle ese tipo de documentos
solamente una prueba de domicilio
si un comentario que interesante con
respecto a las elecciones que acaban de
realizarse aquí en canadá la nota es
votar por los conservadores es votar por
las armas dicen víctimas en canadá y
claudette la piel responde el problema
no se encuentra en las armas pero más
bien en la salud mental del que dispara
el arma claro pero lo ideal sería que
las órdenes menos disponibles ni sean
accesibles a los que tengan problemas
mentales y no tengan problemas mentales
nadie se acondicionará con armas en sus
casas aquí tengo un comentario sobre
campesinas guatemaltecas en canadá rompe
en silencio sobre condiciones de vida y
laborales en granjas y aquí dice
cindy medrano antes de hacer estas
publicaciones deberían de asesorarse
bien y averiguar si es cierto yo trabajé
en la golden y esto es totalmente
mentira nosotras éramos las que
queríamos horas extras para trabajar y
era muy rara vez que nos permitieran
hacer ese tipo de res extras y nos
pagaban 12.65 la hora dólares
canadienses dice cindy medrano
bueno decirle que efectivamente si nos
asesoramos y nos informamos las fuentes
estaban ahí las trabajadoras estaban
denunciando lo frente a organismos de
derechos humanos y no exactamente
en el caso de eso pero ahora acaba de
salir un fallo de justicia
donde hubo 12 trabajadores guatemaltecos
explotados humillados que sufrieron
acoso psicológico físico le hicieron un
juicio al propietario de la empresa y
ganaron el cuesta después de tres años
pero ganaron trescientos mil dólares
cada uno no 300 mil que se integran pero
de todas maneras es un hecho es un hecho
histórico porque es primera vez que
trabajadores temporales van a juicio y
le ganan a la empresa y hay que ver lo
que dictaminó también la jueza cuando
uno lee el fallo entonces es claro que
si hay problemas muy serios con los
trabajadores
no en todas
acá tengo un comentario sobre dónde
están los niños malnutridos del mundo
escribe miriam alarcón también y dice a
la globalización no le importan los
niños pobres da lo mismo que mueran por
desnutrición u obesidad dos caras de la
malnutrición para los ricos del planeta
solo son daños colaterales de un sistema
económico injusto este era un tema que
habías hecho vos paloma también que creo
no sé si era una entrevista con unicef
canadá o en una investigación de unicef
y una nueva investigación en la que
mostraba que tanto la malnutrición tanto
la desnutrición como la obesidad eran
eran causas que se veían en muchas
regiones del mundo y que no estaba
necesariamente definidas por la cantidad
de comida sino por el tipo de comida
entonces a veces la hace la comida menos
de menos calidad es más barata entonces
en algunas regiones del mundo les dan
comida que los engorda entonces son
obesos los niños pero no están bien
nutridos exacto
un último es un comentario de edwin león
arias con respecto al tema la visión y
generosidad de johana botero creadora de
enfermeras en canadá el león dice buenos
días quisiera saber cómo puedo contactar
a esta persona para que me oriente y de
esta manera poder viajar a canadá
también soy enfermero profesional con 18
años de experiencia está en el sitio web
puso su dirección para que la contacten
justamente yo voy a hacer un pedido
especial antes terminamos especial que
todos miremos la cámara creo que es esa
la cámara una sonrisa para sacar la foto
pasamos como 15 minutos tratando de
lograr una foto donde estemos y no está
pero yo tengo los lentes no tiene una
foto
ahora vamos a conversar sobre los temas
que cada uno destaca esta semana paloma
si vos nos vas a hablar de la creación
de la casa de las américas que es la
primera aquí en el continente
norteamericano este ambiente se trata de
un proyecto que tiene muchos años
evolucionando comenzó con el organismo
latinarte pero se han reunido a este
proyecto a esta idea de la casa de las
américas a las américas o la mención de
sameji que muchos muchos empresarios
muchos organismos comunitarios muchos
artistas y son 32 miembros ahora que
pueden ser o instituciones o individuos
que se unieron a este proyecto para
crear esta casa que es un espacio físico
en el que en el que quieren que la gente
el de origen latinoamericano las
diferentes comunidades latinoamericanas
porque no es una sola hay que decirlo
como las américas no son una sola cosa
sino tan diversa y tan vasta lo mismo
las comunidades latinoamericanas acá lo
que quieren es que ahí se vayan a reunir
a este espacio para los eventos
culturales para ir a buscar información
asesoría con respecto a la inmigración
para que la gente vaya asesorarse
también para crear una empresa entonces
quieren crear este este lugar donde la
gente son bienvenidos
también en el marco dentro del mes de la
herencia latinoamericana a propósito
para que cayera en la última semana del
mes de la herencia latinoamericana que
se celebra por primera vez aquí en
montreal entonces si la casa de las
américas la mención de sameji que está
en la calle túpac para quien la rebeldes
interés han ido a visitar un poco
exactamente leonardo por primera vez
cambios de rubros cambios de dirección
nada no le presenta la tecnología ni de
ciencia porque por ahí
no porque presentamos un proyecto
especial que tenemos en radio cara
internacional que es producto de las
reuniones que realiza
veamos el jefe de radio qhana
internacional con el grupo de redes
sociales que son las radios asociadas
que tiene un grupo que hacen una reunión
y probablemente dos reuniones si todo
sale bien el año a partir del año que
viene donde tratan de poner en común
cuáles son los objetivos de cada radio
mostrar qué es lo que están produciendo
cuáles son las tecnologías que manejan
para hacer un intercambio para el
crecimiento de todas estas radios en
este caso tenemos un proyecto en
conjunto que viene hace varias ya casi
un año nomás casi dos años que se llama
escenas de la vida extra que está en
todas en las cinco lenguas de radio
canal internacional y también está
promocionada en los sitios de nuestras
radios también adelante también
participar tienen contenidos exacto y lo
que es esas escenas de vida es en
aproximadamente dos minutos porque
algunos son un minuto 50 y otros dos
minutos 15 que se presentan distintas
temáticas está bien en las primeras en
la visión a ediciones anteriores
las galas de las estaciones del tren
fueron
de fútbol y ahora la nueva la que está
saliendo que sale ahora este fin de
semana es la historia de las radios y
salimos así que ustedes puede ir a
visitar este sitio internet que está
promocionado por supuesto en nuestro
sitio
hershey net punto o sea y hacer un viaje
por lo que fueron y lo que son las
radios del grupo lo 6 las radios
asociadas data de local internacional
inclusive la nuestra en un diaporama de
dos minutos con sonidos e imágenes muy
interesantes realmente muy bien
muchísimas gracias leonardo y bueno
ahora de las radios internacionales
pasamos a la marihuana
[Música]
no sé si hay mensajes y ahí tenemos un
mensajito o la radio canadá dice homero
mendizábal saludos a todos allí
comentarles lo triste que me siento por
estar por estas elecciones ya que mi
país está dividido ya no es el
conciliador de antes espero que se logre
un acuerdo para evitar cualquier muerte
ya que existe bastante tensión y un
saludo y gracias por toda la información
el mensaje de homero mendizábal
pero es quien nos envía el vídeo desde
que haya envío de proxy ex ahora soy muy
bien ahora entonces pablo porque comencé
a hablar de la marihuana otra vez otra
vez porque el 17 de octubre pasado la
semana pasada se cumplió el primer año
de la legalización de la marihuana en
canadá recordemos que en ese momento
canadá se convirtió en el primer país
del g20 en legalizar la marihuana hubo
mucho revuelo la gente temía las
consecuencias de esta legalización de
este escenario
exacto entonces pero un año más tarde
simplemente el doctor robert perro que
es médico psiquiatra en la dirección de
salud pública de montreal él dice que
finalmente un poco como el error del
milenio dice la amenaza que se percibía
no se manifestó entonces puede ser el
único progreso abre sales de ese informe
de lo que sobresale
es que planeo muerte el miedo mayor
consumo no ha habido absolutamente nada
lo que sobresale finalmente es que el
mercado se desabasteció por un lado y no
alcanzó no logró abastecer lo suficiente
a todas las tiendas en canadá para que
la gente pudiera comprar su marihuana
legal segundo que la marihuana legal
resulta siendo más cara que la marihuana
del mercado negro y finalmente pues que
nada hay que hay que continuar
abastecer al mercado legal para que
pueda competir verdaderamente el mercado
negro
leonardo si hay un mensaje ese deprisa
soy uts o tuyo dice hola a todos es
difícil tomar la iniciativa de denunciar
la explotación laboral en canadá pero
creo que es necesario trabajar
personalmente con la confianza en uno
mismo y estar bien informados sobre
nuestros derechos porque todos somos
seres humanos a donde quiera que vayamos
aquí los inmigrantes no somos una opción
para tapar el huesca las desgracias y
respecto a mi refugio ya conversamos un
poco es que crudo fue reelecto primer
ministro de canadá entonces van a
encontrar el desarrollo de esa nota en
nuestro sitio web en ese y net punto sea
como dicen ustedes nos queda todavía 18
algún día tenemos que sacarles una foto
por lo que sea
si están trabajando muchísimas gracias
[Música]
aquí
e
[Música]